en 1944 rv engelstein prouve l'un des
théorèmes les plus controverse de
l'histoire des mathématiques
le torrent de gottstein concerne d'une
machine à qui on donne un nombre à la
première étape la machine décompose ce
nombre qu'on lui donne en base de ou
plus précisément les cris comme une
somme de puissance de 2 mais elle ne
veut pas non plus avoir des exposants
qui ne sont pas des puissances de 2 du
coup la machine dès qu'on pose aussi les
exposants en somme de puissance de 2
mais aussi les exposants des exposants
et ainsi de suite
on obtient alors la notation héréditaire
aux bases 2 de notre nombre et on peut
se convaincre que ton ombre entier
naturel à une unique notation
héréditaire en reste de la machine de
goodstein transforme alors que tous les
deux de la notation crédit terre en
trois et soustrait un aux résultats elle
obtient alors un nouveau nombre qu'elle
va manger à nouveau mais cette fois elle
va écrire ce nombre en notation
héréditaire embrasse 3 c'est à dire
qu'elle va décomposer le nombre en une
somme de puissance de 3 qui peut
potentiellement fait intervenir un
nombre plus petit que trois comme un ou
deux la machine de goodstein remplace
alors tous les trois par des 4 puis re
tranche un essor le résultat est comme
vous l'imaginez la machine goodkind
reprend le résultat le décomposant
notation en réalité en basse 4
remplacent les quatre par des cinq
retranche en paix ressort le résultat et
ainsi de suite
voyons ce qu'il se passe si on lui donne
nombreux 3 pour commencer la machine
décompose trois ans base de ce qui lui
donne trois est égal à 2 + 1
elle transforme le 2 ou 3 ce qui lui
donne 3 + 1 puis re tranche 1 pour
obtenir trois bombes as3 ce nom ne
s'écrit tout simplement 3 du coup quand
la machine orange 3 elle remplace le
trois parrains 4 pour obtenir 4 puis re
tranche 1 ce qui lui donne quatre moins
égal 3 notation a réalisé en basse 4,3
s'écrit tout simplement 3 la machine
remplace tous les cas de ces notations
par cinq
et comme il n'ya pas de 4 ça ne change
pas le résultat enfin elle lui
retrancher 1 et obtient 3 moins égale 2
or 2 c'est également la notation
héréditaire en bas 5 du nombre d'eux
donc quand la machine remplace les cinq
par des 6 2 reste inchangé mais la
machine doit lui retirer ans
du coup on obtient 1 et enfin après un
dernier tour
la machine obtient finalement au moins
inquiète égal à zéro si on commence par
donner le nombre 3 la machine de gouch
klein la suite que l'on obtient fait 3 4
3 2 1 0 c'est ce qu'on appelle la suite
de gucci times de graines 3 voyons ce
qui se passe maintenant si on commence
avec la graine 4 la machine écrit quatre
ans notation héréditaire en baisse 2 ce
qui lui donne deux au carré après une
itération où elle remplace les deux par
détroit et en tranchant elle obtient 3
au cube - 20 ans qui fait 26 morts en
passe 3,26 écrit deux fois 3 au carré
plus deux fois trois plus deux
remplaçants les trois par des quatre en
retranchant un elle obtient deux fois
quatre carrés plus deux fois 4 plus dans
ce qui donne 41 puis au prochain passage
la machine est créé 41 sous la forme
deux fois 4 au carré + 2 x 4 plus en
remplacent les quatre par des cinq est
retranché 1 ce qui lui donne deux fois 5
au carré plus deux fois 5 soit soixante
bombes accélérer un petit peu ce qu'on
va faire toutes les opérations on
obtient ensuite 83/100 939 173 211 2 150
3 299
bref on a l'impression que l'on obtient
lé nombre toujours plus grand et
pourtant les mathématiciens ont prouvé
que cette croissance
ne dure que pendant trois fois de
puissance 402 millions six cent
cinquante 3209 itération je sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte à quel point ce
nombre est gargantuesque il est beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus grand qu'un
google ce qui veut dire que si on
mettait tous les ordinateurs de la terre
pour calculer les éléments de la suite
de good time de graines 4 eh bien ces
ordinateurs tournerait tournoi à tour
devrait encore jusqu'à la nuit des temps
et en fait l'énergie noire exploserait
ses ordinateurs mis en avant qu'il
puisse arriver à une fraction de ce
qu'il faudrait pour se rendre compte que
cette suite va finir par arrêter de
croître plus fou encore au bout de trois
fois deux puissances 402 millions six
cent cinquante 3211 - une itération la
suite de coach times retombera jusqu'à 0
incroyable après tous ces calculs après
avoir flirté avec l'infini la suite de
groot stein reviendra tout simplement à
0 mais du coup qu'en est il de la suite
de gucci stein de graines 5 ou de
graines 12 ou de graines 19
et bien c'est suite de goodstein ont des
croissances qui sont encore plus un
milieu zm en rapide par exemple la suite
go shine de graines 19 commence par 19
puis 7000 milliards puis 10 puis sont
154 et ensuite on a 10 puissance 2180 et
ainsi de suite avec des exposants
toujours peu monstrueusement énorme
il est très difficile d'imaginer que
cette chute finira par revenir à zéro
et pourtant le théorème de goodstein
affirme que tout de suite de gouch times
finira par retomber à zéro même si ça
peut prendre un temps mais monstreux par
exemple si on prend la suite de goodkind
cren 12 le temps qu'il faut le nombre
d'itérations qu'il faut pour qu'elle
revienne à 0
eh bien on a montré qu'elle était
supérieure au nombre de g
or si vous vous souvenez de l'épisode 1
le nombre de grammes
c'est vraiment monstrueusement et non
mais la seule preuve que l'on est de ce
théorème de goldstein repose sur
l'existence des nombres trans fini ce
dont on a parlé dans l'épisode 8
souvenez vous qu'il existe un plus petit
ordinale transmis aux médias et que l'on
peut combiner des ordinaux avec des
additions démultiplication des
exportations pour former des ordinaux
toujours plus grand l'idée de woodson
c'est de partir du notation héréditaire
en baisse n est de remplacer toutes les
occurrences de haine dans cette notation
parlent ordinale ou méga ce qui va être
important pour la suite c'est que la
transformation en ordinale pour la base
elle est une transformation strictement
croissance qui veut dire que si je donne
aux nombres strictement plus grand à la
fonction fn qui effectuent cette
transformation en ordinale alors
l'ordinaire que j'obtiens va être aussi
strictement plus grand et en particulier
fn 2 x va être toujours strictement plus
grands en termes d'ordina le fn 2x moins
un an la deuxième chose à retenir c'est
que en gros si on change de base
l'ordinateur on obtient reste inchangé
donc par exemple c'est plus clair de
voir ça sur un exemple si je prends 3 ^
3 ^ 3 pouces 3 donc ça c'est notation
héréditaire en baisse 3 si j'effectue la
transformation en ordinale pour la basse
3 2 ce nombre
j'obtiens oméga puissance oméga
puissance oméga plus oméga et ça c'est
aussi le nom que j'obtiens cigéo fait la
transformation pour la base 4 du nombre
quatre puissances cad puissance 4 + 4 on
est maintenant prêt pour prouver au turn
doggystyle donc on part de n'importe
quelle graine on va appeler x2 cette
graine x2 donc ça va être le nom
notamment on donne à la machine et que
la machine va décomposé en notation un
éditeur en base 2
ou ensuite appelé x3 le deuxième nombre
que la machine régurgite puis x 4 et
ainsi de suite
par exemple si la graine et es19 alors
x2 va être égale à dix neuf qu'on écrit
en notation et réalité en baisse 2 du
coup on a exhorté aussi illégal 1-2 ^ ^
plus de +1 ensuite x3 c'est ce que
j'obtiens ce que je remplace tous les
deux par détroit donc ça fait 3 ^ 3 ^ 3
+ 3 + 1 - 1 puisqu'il faut retrancher 1
à chaque fois donc c'est juste 3 ^ 3 ^ 3
+ 3 et ensuite pour obtenir x4 je
remplaçais 3 par des quatre ça nous fait
400 ans quatre puissances cat +4 et je
suis encore une fois le moins un que je
dois faire à la fin de l'opération de la
machine de lupstein et du coup je me
tiens 4 puissance 4 puissance 4 + 3 et
ainsi de suite
cette suite de goodstein on va associer
une suite d'ordino de goodstein alpha-2
alfa3a si la suite ou alpha n le énième
éléments de cette suite va être le
nombre ordinale qu'on n'obtient
lorsqu'on applique la transformation
pour la base n au nombre x n
autrement dit on définit alpha n est
égal à f haine de xn donc si je prends
l'exemple de la graine 19
on avait vu que x2 est égal à 2 ^ ^ +2
plus sain et bien alpha 2 c'est ce que
je retiens lorsque je remplace tous les
deux de cette notation par des oméga et
ça me donne alpha 2 est égal à oméga
puissance oméga puissance oméga plus
oméga plus et doit même façon on n'avait
vu que x3 et elle est égale à 3 ^ 3 ^ 3
+ 3 donc pour obtenir alpha 3 jean
placent tous les trois par des oméga et
ça me donne aux médias puissance aux
médias puissance mais il ya plus aux
médias puis la même façon j'ai alpha 4
est égal au méga puissance oméga
puissance oméga +3 et ainsi de suite
et ce qui est remarquable c'est que la
suite d'ordino de greenstein est une
suite strictement décroissante et on va
le prouver maintenant mais ça va piquer
un petit peu donc n'hésitez pas à
ignorer
les 30 prochaines secondes la première
est content si vous n'êtes pas très à
l'aise avec les ordinands on sait que
alpha n + 1 est égal à fn + 1 appliquée
xn puissant mais par construction d ixen
on sait aussi que alpha n est égal à fn
de xm qui est égal à fn que sein de xl
plus simple plus un puisque xmp campus 1
est ce que l'on a obtenue en remplaçant
tous les haines de la notation crédit
car de luxe n en n + 1 mais quand on
applique fn et a fait une puissante ou
cnn puissants sont remplacés par des
oligarques n'obtient donc les mêmes
résultats
du coup alpha n est égale à la fnp sans
appliquer à x n plus en plus fins
or on sait que fnp s'en est strictement
croissante du coup fn puissant appliqué
à ixelles plus en plus on veut être
strictement plus grand que fn puissant
appliqué à xm cuistre non déduit alors
alpha n est strictement plus grand que
alpha et une puce francs cqfd
la suite al fan des ordis nos deux beach
dernier donc strictement décroissante
or on un théorème absolument fondamental
sur les ordinands qui me dit que tout de
suite strictement décroissante d'ordino
finit forcément par descendre jusqu'à 0
sauf que sauf que si la suite des
nombres entiers de goodstein la suite xl
si cette suite lan continue à l'infini
alors on pourrait toujours associé
jusqu'à l'infini à tout élément xn de
cette suite à un ordinale non nul
du coup le fait qu'ils aient les organes
ou finissent par tomber à zéro implique
que la suite c'est des nombres entiers
de goodstein ne peut pas continuer à
l'infini sans jamais retombé jusqu'à 0
du coup on vient de montrer que à
l'instar de la suite des ordis nos deux
groupes stein la suite des nombres
entiers de goodstein doit tomber jusqu'à
0 on vient de montrer que la suite de
gottstein finit bien par finir à 0
quelle que soit la graine initial
sauf que sauf que pour y arriver on a dû
utiliser ces nombres trans fini et du
cou par un raisonnable de se dire que
s'ils n'ont transmis qui n'ont pas
vraiment l'air d'exister en pratique et
qui n'existe pas dans l'arithmétique de
p and o eh bien il semble raisonnable de
demander à ce que l'on puisse trouver
une preuve qu'ils n'utilisent pas ces
nombres dont on n'a pas vraiment trouvé
l'existence
eh bien non en 1982 kirby et parisse ont
démontré que ce théorème de goodstein ne
pouvait pas être prouvé dans
l'arithmétique de p and o dans laquelle
ces nombres trans fini n'existe pas ou
autrement dit il n'est pas possible de
déduire des axiomes de l'arithmétique de
p and o que la suite de good time va
toujours finir à 0 pour le pessimiste ça
veut dire qu'on ne peut pas vraiment
faire confiance à la preuve de good
times puisqu'on ne peut pas vraiment
faire confiance aux nombres 30 fini et
du coup bas tout ce que je viens de
raconter dans cette vidéo ne sert à rien
pour l'optimiste en revanche ça veut
dire que les actions de rythme éthique
de piano sont incomplets et que si on
veut vraiment comprendre les nombres si
on veut vraiment sentir et nombres
entiers naturels et prouver des choses
alors sujet il nous faut inclure des
actions qui vont bien plus loin que les
nombres entiers naturels des actions qui
embrasse l'infini et notamment
l'existence de ces nombres trans fini
car dossier tranche que cela puisse
paraître ces nombres trans fini nous
renseigne sur les nombres fini que l'on
pense connaître dernière fois on avait
parlé de l'arithmétique de paix à nos
âges vous avez posé un mini défilé à
savoir écrire dans le langage du rythme
éthique de paix à nous le fait qu'il
existe un nombre
on a fini de nombreux pros mais du coup
il y en a pas mal par niveau qui se
seront collées à la tâche et ça m'a fait
super plaisir et plusieurs d'entre vous
vont trouver des bonnes réponses
du coup j'ai un petit peu lever le défi
dans les commentaires à elle vous est
demandé de trouver la traduction la plus
courte possible d'où concise possible du
fait qu'il existe une infinité de
nombres premiers
le premier à voir une donner une réponse
assez remarquablement concise et
incertain quand un air qui a écrit cette
formule ici qui contient 25 caractères
cette formule a été aussi découverte le
même jour par baptiste coquinot alors
pourquoi est-ce que cette formule décrit
bien le théorème qu'il utilise une
infinité de nombreux premiers
il vient pour montrer qu'il existe une
infinité de vos premiers et bien ça
revient à dire qu'en fait si on prend
n'importe quel nombre il y aura toujours
un nombre premier pour rang que ce
nombre
du coup si on avait une liste de
nombreux premiers et bien ce qu'on veut
dire c'est qu'il en existe un qui est au
delà de cette liste et ça ça revient à
dire qu'il ya une infinité de nombreux
premiers donc tout ce qu'on a à dire
c'est que si on prend n'importe quel
nombre entier
n alors il va exister un nombre au delà
de haine qui lui sera aussi premier donc
ce nombre là sont ces notations
correspondre au nombre ainsi naturel n +
m qui est bien plus grand que n
et dire que n + m et premier ça revient
à dire que si on essaie de l'éclair
comme le produit de deux entier c'est
fouad est alors forcément il va devrait
avoir l'un des nombreux c ou d qui va
être égal à 1
autrement dit à chaque fois que l'on
peut écrire n + m sous la forme c'est
fouad et alors il ya forcément un des
deux entier qui est égal à 1
ça correspond bien à une application qui
est écrite ici contador a ensuite trouvé
une petite astuce pour récrire à peu
près la même chose mais avec moins de
symboles et là l'astuce en fait c'est de
remplacer en gros les
brossez aidé par ac et sd et ça ça
permet de retirer deux symboles mais il
est possible de faire mieux et ses
ruines et détenteur du record instant
non battus je suis pas sûr qu'il soit où
qu'il est possible de le battre
puisqu'il ya aussi à trouver une façon
d'exprimer le fait que lisbonne infinité
de nombreux produits en vain symbole
seulement donc quand je dis vive un
symbole c'est en exécution des espaces
et les parenthèses qui sont juste des là
pour faciliter à la compréhension de la
formule et donc voici la formule magique
de ses ruines qui est d'ailleurs été
découverte peu de temps après par
baptiste kutino et l'astuce de cette
formule est de remplacer donc les cdci
donc par des notations sont pas
importants mais l'idée ici c'est que on
va pas dire que à x b est égal au nombre
premier que l'on cherche
on va dire que s à foix ssb est égal au
nombre bruit que mon chat est de cette
manière on impôts directement le fait
que les facteurs essayer les diviseurs à
gauche du nombres premiers sont
forcément supérieure ou égale à 2 et ça
on a envie de dire que c'est impossible
donc il suffit de dire qu' il n'est pas
possible que il faut de dire que ss à
foix ssb est égal à le nombres premiers
qui ont charge la nar fois aussi je vous
avais parlé des axiomes de la logique et
ça fait réagir plusieurs parmi vous qui
considèrent notamment qu'il n'y a pas
une seule logique et du coup il est faux
de parler de la logique est en effet il
n'ya pas la logique mais il faut
vraiment parler de logique au pluriel il
ya plusieurs logiques et les actions
dont vous ai parlé l'année un poids
correspondent à une logique en
particulier qui est logique des
prédicats du premier ordre et ce qui est
vrai c'est que dans le cadre de cette
logique du premier ordre
il y a des implications d'un fait on n'a
pas besoin de tous les symboles que vous
et montrez n'a pas besoin du symbole la
flèche vers la droite puisque à flèche b
est en fait logiquement équivalent dans
la logique du premier roman par une fois
à la proposition non a ou b du coup ne
peut remplacer à chaque fois les flèches
par des noms
à roubaix pense un petit peu plus loin à
écrire pas beaucoup plus long et on n'a
pas besoin non plus du symbole il existe
puisque dire qu' il existe x tel que p 2
x est logiquement équivalent encore une
fois dans la logique du premier ordre à
dire qu'il est faux de dire que pour
toutes xe non p 2 x du coup on pourrait
écrire toute la logique du premier ordre
en sans utiliser le symbole il existe et
sans utiliser le flash vers la droite
mais on verra d'autres logiques dans
cette série sur scène sol où ce n'est
pas le cas je vous avais demandé si de
proposer un accès aux manoeuvres maximum
de l'arithmétique de piano qui
permettait d'exclure les branches
parallèle des nombres entiers naturels
orange bleu nous a rappelé les axiomes
de paix à nos deux de kind en tout cas
une certaine version de ses actions de
paix à nos deux quines la solution pour
exclure cette branche parallèle des
nombres entiers naturels réside dans ces
axiomes de piano de the king
vous avez dit que les axiomes de piano
c'est pas la même chose que les actions
de l'arithmétique de piano et en
particulier dans les axiomes dopé
anneaux il ya un axiome qui est l'axiome
de récurrence qui est un seul axiome
contrairement au schéma d'action de
récurrence dont ont apparu dans
l'épisode précédent
l'axiome de récurrence de l'axiomatique
de kind et lui un petit peu particulier
puisque et c'est un axiome du second
ordre dans le sens où il fait intervenir
un ensemble il dit cet axiome que si je
prends n'importe quel ensemble d'objets
de la théorie si j'arrive à montrer que
zéro à partir à cet ensemble
si j'arrive à montrer que si n
appartient cet ensemble alors une puce
appartient cet ensemble alors tous les
objets de la théorie de paix à nous
appartiennent pas forcément à cet
ensemble
cet axiome rejette l'existence d'une
branche parallèle puisque s'il existe
une branche parallèle on pourrait
construire un ensemble s tels que zéro à
partir de 7 ans anglais est tel que à
chaque sens qu'un élément appartient cet
ensemble son successeur appartient
forcément glossy mais tel que cet
ensemble ne contiennent pas tous les
objets en particulier nous tiens ne
contiendra pas les objets de la branche
parallèle
du coup cet axiome exclu l'existence des
broches parallèle
le problème avec cet axiome en plus de
devoir utiliser ce symbole
d'appartenance en plus ce cet axiome et
ses mauvais parce qu il quantifie sur un
ensemble d'objets de la théorie et on
n'a pas le droit vraiment ou qu'il n'ait
pas vraiment
bien on va dire de quantifier sur un des
ensembles d'objets notamment parce
qu'une fois qu'on a quantifié sur des
ensembles d'objets on ne peut plus
appliqué le théorème de complétude de
gödel je parviens du terme de complétude
et passionné d'incomplétude ce terme de
complétude qui est un thème très
rassurant on dit que si dans une théorie
du premier ordre où il ya que des trucs
du premier ordre il n'y a pas de de
constitution sur des ensembles si une
théorie du premier ordre et logiquement
cohérente à dire qu'on peut pas conclure
une chose et sont opposés avec les
axiomes de cette théorie
alors cette théorie décrit quelque chose
de vraiment vrai que quelque chose là ce
qu'on appelle un modèle c'est à dire qui
est une façon un peu assez explicite au
concevoir un objet qui satisfait les
axiomes de cette théorie
bref tout ça pour dire que les axiomes
de p and o ne s'en fait pas si populaire
pas si utilisé que sa part et
mathématicien alors que les actuelles de
l'arithmétique de p and o sont sous
beaucoup plus étudier parce qu'ils sont
parce qu'ils correspondent à la logique
du premier ordre et que c'est à la
logique du premier ordre qui l'écrit le
mur en tout cas parmi celles qu'on a
trouvé les nombres entiers naturels de
façon la plus simple qui soit elle
espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode là
on commence à voir qu'il existe
plusieurs mathématiques et ce sera
clairement le cas
la prochaine fois puisqu'on va parler du
très controverse actions du choix si
vous avez aimé ça l'épisode social
lakehal aux commentaires le partage et
pensez à vous abonner pour traquer les
futurs épisodes de mercy aussi peur que
leur nom et j'espère que je verrai la
prochaine fois bien sûr le combat sera
certainement très long on ne peut pas
abattre à monstres mythologiques et sans
un minimum de patience of the world